en este vídeo hablaremos de una idea
crucial para el correcto funcionamiento
de una economía basada en un sistema de
mercado esta idea es la de los derechos
de propiedad es la idea en la que todos
están de acuerdo en quién es el dueño de
qué cosa y qué puede hacer con esa
propiedad y para muchos de nosotros que
vivimos en lugares con fuertes derechos
de propiedad
vemos esto por hecho sabemos quién es el
dueño de casa sabemos qué es lo que
puede hacer con ella y si el dueño
decide vender su casa todos sabemos cómo
es el proceso pero en algunos lugares
del mundo y en algunos momentos de la
historia esto no era tan claro alguien
podía decir que era dueño de una casa
pero otra persona podría vivir en ella y
decir yo he vivido aquí más de diez años
por lo que es mi casa ahora o quizá
podría amenazar al dueño de la casa y
obligarlo a venderla a un precio
bajísimo o también el gobierno podría
decidir que le quita la propiedad al
dueño todo esto infringe y debilita los
derechos de propiedad ahora vamos a
hacer un experimento mental para
comprender por qué los derechos de
propiedad son básicos para el correcto
funcionamiento de una
de mercado continuamos con la analogía
de las casas imaginemos que en esta
economía existen casas azules y su dueño
es esta persona también existen casas
rosadas que se ven así y su dueño es
esta persona así como también existen
casas anaranjadas que tienen el techo
abovedado y cuyo dueño es esta persona
vamos a suponer que todas estas personas
están interesadas en vender sus casas
quizás se van a mudar a otro lugar
también existe un mercado de compradores
potenciales que son estos que estoy
dibujando si estamos en una economía de
mercado funcional con correctos derechos
de propiedad es probable que haya
personas interesadas en la casa azul y
la persona que ofrezca más por esa casa
se la queda digamos que esta persona
ofrece pagar esta cantidad por ella y la
propiedad de esa casa pasa a esta
persona lo mismo ocurre con la casa
rosada- hay más personas interesadas en
la casa rosada- y esta persona fue la
que ofreció más por ella pagó esta
cantidad que es un poco mayor que la de
la casa azul y ahora es el dueño de la
casa y quizá muchas personas están
interesado
en la casa anaranjada a lo mejor les
gusta el techo abovedado quizás subasta
en la casa y hay muchas ofertas por ella
hasta que esta persona gana al final y
paga toda esta cantidad que es mucho
para hacer el dueño de esta casa también
vamos a imaginar que el costo de
construcción de todas estas fue más o
menos el mismo que es lo que va a pasar
en este mercado pues los constructores o
las personas dueñas de otro tipo de
casas van a decir caray puedo ganar
mucho dinero si vendo una casa como la
anaranjada el mercado les da un anuncio
de venta de hecho todas las casas tienen
anuncios de venta pero al compararlas
vemos que se obtiene más dinero por la
casa anaranjada que por la casa azul así
que si la construcción de todas las
casas cuesta lo mismo entonces
comenzaremos a construir más casas como
la casa anaranjada así que comenzarán a
construirse más casas anaranjadas y
quizá algunas personas remodelará en
casas de otro tipo para que tengan el
techo abovedado podemos imaginar que
esto va a ocurrir porque el anuncio de
venta indica que esto es lo que
prefieren los consumidores es aquí donde
se encuentra
ahora imaginemos un mundo menos ideal en
el cual vivimos los humanos la mayor
parte de la historia e incluso ahora
existen lugares así en algunas partes
del mundo en donde no hay derechos de
propiedad claros en donde esta persona
dice que tiene esta casa para vender
pero que es cuestionado por los
compradores y llega a otra persona
afirmando que él es el dueño de esa casa
porque tiene pruebas de que su bisabuelo
fue su dueño y que nunca la vendió y
además llega a otra persona fuertemente
armada al que no le importa que papeles
tengan los otros dos y que se quiere
quedar con la casa por la fuerza cuando
creen que esta persona esté dispuesta a
pagar a la primer persona por la casa en
estas circunstancias pues es muy poco
probable que esta persona reciba toda
esta cantidad de dinero por la casa ya
que es una inversión riesgosa porque no
sabe si al pagarle a esa persona podrá
ser dueño de la casa quizá alguien se
anime a pagar muy poco por la casa o
quizá nadie esté dispuesto a comprarla
en este caso se destruye el anuncio de
venta y cuando esto sucede todo el
sistema de mercado se destruye ya que
el sistema se basa en lo que las
personas demandan y usa en el precio
para indicar cuánto están dispuestos a
pagar por las cosas pero esto también
supone que cuando compras algo te
vuelves el dueño y no va a ser disputado
y que la persona a quien le compras es
el dueño del objeto y tiene el derecho
de venderlo cuando esto ocurre se dice
que tenemos una falla de mercado en
otros vídeos hemos visto otros tipos de
sistemas de mercado por ejemplo la
economía de estado en los ejemplos
extremos de esta economía no existe la
propiedad privada y quizá piensen que
esa es la solución al problema de los
derechos de propiedad pero este tipo de
economía tiene sus propios problemas y
de hecho casi ninguna de estas economías
ha demostrado ser exitosa históricamente
estas economías tienen un gran problema
de incentivos ya que si es el gobierno
el que dice quién construye esa cosa y
quién recibe esa cosa hay muy poco
incentivo para innovar o tratar de
construir más o de invertir como lo
hemos comentado en otros vídeos hasta
aquí vamos a dejar esta introducción a
la idea de los derechos de propiedad
e investigar qué tanta infraestructura
tienen las sociedades como los estados
unidos como méxico y como la mayoría de
las naciones en la actualidad para
asegurar los derechos de propiedad nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo